tras meses de tensiones y protestas en
las calles pro y antigubernamentales
renuncio el primer ministro racing de
rajapaksa quien cedió a los
manifestantes para abrir el camino a un
gobierno de unidad y calmar la crisis
social y económica horas antes hubo
enfrentamientos en colombo y otras
ciudades un parlamentario murió durante
la protesta en la ciudad del itam bbwaa
tras los hechos del gobierno impuso un
toque de queda que fue desafiado por
algunos de los manifestantes nos
sirvieron los llamados a la calma de su
hermano y presidente del país votaba ya
rajapaksa condenó enérgicamente los
actos de violencia que tienen lugar por
parte de quienes incitan y participan
independientemente de sus lealtades
políticas la violencia no resolverá los
problemas actuales pido a todos los
ciudadanos que mantengan la calma y
ejerzan moderación instó a todos a
trabajar juntos para resolver esta
crisis pero los manifestantes también
quieren que contaba ya renuncia el país
está sumido en una grave escasez de
alimentos combustible electricidad y
medicinas en la peor crisis económica
desde la independencia de los británicos
en 1972 la situación se ha agravado tras
las acusaciones de mala administración
económica que pesan sobre los hermanos
yo no diría que es un gobierno es un
régimen gobernado por un conjunto de
ladrones asesinos esperan que la gente
sea violente la gente no es violenta la
gente está teniendo estas protestas
durante los últimos meses sin ningún
tipo de violencia o de la base cerró el
mando verdad en eso balance
la nación insular de 22 millones de
habitantes tiene solo 50 millones de
dólares en reservas y se ha enfrentado a
un impago de la deuda externa por 51 mil
millones de dólares el país que depende
en gran medida del turismo ha visto
mermado sus ingresos debido a la
pandemia y a la lenta recuperación
económica